I want us now to think back to when
we're doing parabolas right we're doing
promise so I'm not to this example um
you guys are sick of this but I'm going
to use it anyway okay let's think about
the domain of this first right because
we've been looking at the domain of it
earlier what kinds of values of x up off
limits to this equation I think
anybody's Oaks that I put in there and
finish block and stopped working like
yeah can you put in 0 that gonna work
you can write you'll get 0 square plus 5
all 20 plus 6 we just get six can you
put in really big numbers yeah there's
no limits he put in small numbers really
negative numbers there's nothing that's
going to cause you problems like over
here okay so how do I state its domain
if it can go anywhere remember I gave
you a on a definition for this being
that I can put in anything I will say
all real values of x okay now you might
say why do I have to put that word
really mad it's a bit of a teaser for
the fact that there are other kinds of
values of numbers that aren't real and
you can learn about that in future years
but that's the way it status can we get
to arrange things get a little snippy on
okay y equals x squared plus 5x plus 6
let's get a really brief picture of this
if you factorize that what would you get
x squared plus 5x plus 6 the pair of
numbers add to this multiply this got
your pair numbers two or three right so
this is my factorization do you agree
with that once I factorize it in this
way I can read directly off it what the
roots are right well y equals your what
are the roots of hits now that
fundraiser yeah it's the negatives yet
negative 2
two and near three those are my two
roots yes okay now grab others are
either happy travelers facing up or
they're facing down is this what happy
one or as a sad is a frantic x squared
plus 5x plus 6 what value tells me
others happy or sad it's it's actually
this is a happy one right the way I know
is the number out the front here the
number attached to x squared okay in
this case it's positive one I says since
it's positive it's going up so this is
roughly what it's going to look like ok
now let's just have a look at this
person terms of domain can you see it
just goes everywhere I've got none of
these weird bottom lines that are
breaking my function okay that's why the
domain is or we're both everything sweet
there but there are some values of Y I
can't get do you see that some values
that no matter what X you put in I won't
be able to go there for instance like
down here whatever this value is ok I
can put in x equals 0 at T equals a
million x equals minus in the end I'm
never going to get underneath here so
the question is what's the lowest point
on this parabola that's that's as far as
I can go it has a name starts with a V
don't remember it the vertex like if I
can find where the vertex the vertex
that's the lowest point and I can't ever
go below that right or if it was a sad
traveler there'd be that highest point
and I can't never go above it right does
that make sense so all I need to do is
find where that point is ok now I'll
save you a bit of work I happen to know
where this one is because I pull out
this example all the time right the
coordinates of this this vertex r minus
two and a half that's the easy spot how
do I know that the x value is most one
about itself it's the axis of symmetry
right so it's right between the two
roots minus 2 verse 3 that's got to be
halfway right and ninety-nine percent
sure that if you pop it in you'll get y
equals minus a quarter that's where the
vertex Peters ok so that's where the
vertex is that's the lowest possible
point what does that indicate about
range
where can I go yeah it's there and above
right y equals negative a quarter that's
the lowest i can go and I can go
anywhere above there do you see how this
is a reflection of well how much of the
graph how much are the Cartesian plane
can I go on right and the answer is
there and up does that make sense okay
so I want to draw your attention now if
you haven't already to look at page 58
you can see and there's a few sneaky
examples there right so for instance
let's pull out mm let's have a look at a
question like part I can you see pod I
right so it looks like this yes yes um
effectively yes my you can pick any
value you like and I'll be able to go
there I can input it and it will work
I'm really quickly going to switch
sketch um I ok and maybe you want to
have a basic sketch doesn't have to be
beautiful ok just enough to work off of
a bit it looks like this this is high
and that value is negative to that these
okay now what is this thing um as it
happens I don't need to know what the
equation of this thing is to work out
what it's doing me and reg I just need
to look at it okay if you're curious
it's an exponential it looks to me like
it's 2 2 minus X minus 2 of the equation
like I said it's not important just look
at the thing right firstly let's look
about this pond that donate what that is
X are a cave where can I room or
alternatively where can I not go are
there any spots that break the function
either Xbox a break the potion ya think
I'm just thinking about one step at a
time I'm on domain right we'll get some
minus 2 in a second right a domain is
horizontal thank you remember
alphabetical speaking domain comes and
then range which means this is X and
this is y so this is horizontal and this
is very cool now horizontally I can go
anywhere I please do you see that there
are none of these weird vertical lines
that are breaking things alternatively
the graduate of stops right it's not
like I said oh there we go there's a
spot and I'm finished right that arrow
indicates it goes and it goes forever
okay so being that i have an error there
I'm going all the way over that way to
the left I'm going all the way over this
way to the right everything's fair game
there's no holes in it or anything right
so therefore i can tell you domain is
all real values I'll bet they all check
out okay now when we get to arrange
things start to get a bit stickier this
minus 2 this is the problem okay now
don't forget by the way this is a
horizontal line so what's its equation y
equals minus 2 okay so that's where do
you notice it's not it right that means
I'm never going to get there and they
were actually going to reach it I'll get
very very close but I won't touch it ok
so is y equals minus 2 is it part of the
range is it a value i can actually get
and it's just know that was the whole
point of saying i'll get closer and
closer
close up but never actually reach it
right so I'm not there am I above or
below I'm clearly above right that means
greater than right so i would say y is
greater than not inclusive so i don't
have an extra line there greater than
negative 2 i'm just reading it off the
ground okay now you can see if we have a
look at l which is a bit sneaker this is
a night owl Astro really mean the brief
crap looks like this okay forgive my
figure my listeners okay now domain I'm
just going to go past this is exactly
the same that previous function it's any
value you can put them all in the arrows
tell me I'll go from rev up and on
nothing stops me so that's what the
domain is all be about it but when you
have a look at range again there's
something a little more interested in
right I'm fascitis this dotted line
clearly indicated even the don't line
but you can see it's kind of implied by
the shape of the thing right what's the
equation of my asymptotes my dog lying
in this case it's horizontal right so
it's y equals something and it looks to
me like it's right on the axis yeah
right of the exercise zero yes can I get
2y equals 0 I cut there's nothing on the
picture that tells me I'll ever get
there I'll get very close but I won't
get there okay so i won't get 20 but i'm
not just anywhere above right there's
also an upper limit that I can't go past
which is looking at the ground for right
now can I get to fall I can't get to
fall right in fact that's exactly where
I passed through so therefore i would
say y is greater than zero right but
simultaneously it's got to be less than
or equal to 4 less
for now do you notice remember I pointed
out these are all right or or or because
you can't be both at the same time the
number you can come up with that does
all of these right but there are loads
of numbers that are greater than 0 and
less than or equal to 4 at the same time
aren't there like one is fine to respire
it's both of those at the same time okay
so just like I did here i'm going to
encapsulate these into one inequality
rather than two separate one I'll say 0
is less than Y which is less than or
equal to 4 this is another way of
stating exactly the same thing just no
please please be careful here I don't
include 0 that's why there isn't a
little extra line to indicate equality
but here I include four right so we call
these boundary values like what are your
edges cut get to this boundary so it's
not included but you can get to this one
so that's why it is those are really
sleepy okay